what's going on guys this is rob and
this is this story arc with strange
academy this will actually get us caught
up with the current strange academy run
i think we have like maybe two or three
more issues before the story arc
finishes i could be wrong uh and they
release it monthly which means we
basically have like two or three more
months until the the current story arc
is done so we're kind of caught up for
the moment um what this does here is
kind of funny right i mean i have to
remind myself whenever i sit down to
read this comic that it's designed to be
read from the perspective of like a
teenager right like telling his stories
about teens and so you have this little
moment where emily is with doyle right
now one of the things that's kind of
been hit on although it's not really
overt is that emily kind of had a thing
for doyle and doyle sort of had a thing
for emily it was really more obvious
with doyle than it was emily but you
know it's kind of cool to see this
they're kind of out in the swamp and
they're sharing this little bit of a
moment you know
like little mermaid you know like the
fish are singing and all that kind of
stuff you wanna kiss the girl whoa whoa
i love that song but uh but nonetheless
right it's kind of this funny moment you
know because it's it's one of those
things where you know he kind of talks
about how no one's ever really kissed
him before she's like well let's change
that and she's like you know going for
the kiss and then she's like ah
then she gets set on fire you know and
then she suddenly wakes up and the
reality here is that it was somewhat of
a dream sequence but in essence from her
perspective everything that happened in
the swamp that we talked about in the
last video right where like doyle had
died and all that kind of stuff where
she didn't think any of that was real
and even when she's told by zelma like
you know no no this is not a dream
doyle's dead you're basically in what
passes for a hospital you know and the
the strange academy school for
witchcraft and wizardry are like all
this stuff is real and so for her it
hits her exceedingly hard on a personal
level and there's a couple reasons for
that the first is because of the fact
that doyle was someone she was growing
close to the other reason is because of
well we'll actually kind of talk about
it here in a second that instead we get
this little bit of an explanation right
in terms of like how this happened then
when she asked the question like like
you know you guys are literally a school
for bringing people back you guys can do
all kinds of stuff why can't you bring
him back and the answer she gives is
that it's complicated the reason for
this is that as soon as everything
popped off right doctor strange and all
those guys were there they immediately
whisked emily and doyle back to uh back
to strange academy and then immediately
doctor strange got to work on emily and
when the question was asked why don't we
do anything about doyle right like he's
the he's a descendant of dormammu we can
go to the dark dimension we can have
dormammu kind of quote unquote re-light
the fire in in doyle right basically
bring him back to life that it's not
something that's easily done now stephen
strange is like that's not my concern my
concern right now is to fix emily
because she's close to dying right doyle
is basically already dead and if there
is a way to bring him back we can figure
it out later but i do not want to lose
two students because there's no
guarantee that we can bring emily back
in the same way we can with doyle the
other thing about this though is that
because the nature of emily and the
power she possesses which even at this
point is still a little ambiguous that
in absorbing the energy of doyle as well
as other people what it's basically
meant is she's taken on more energy than
her body can handle so quite literally
it's beginning the process of exploding
now this is where we started to get into
the gods of magic and the reason why is
because steven strange realizes this is
not something he can fix on his own that
what he has to do is basically go to
hogoth right one of the members of the
vashanti now for those of you guys who
are unfamiliar with doctor strange right
doctor strange in marvel comics gets
like 80 of his power from the vashanti
these dudes are on a whole different
level to give you guys perspective here
in strange tales 157 back in like 1967 i
think it was uh when the living tribunal
first appeared the living tribunal used
the rings of ragdor on stephen strange
and with the help of the vashanti he was
able to overpower them now granted
that's the original living tribunal and
his powers kind of changed over the
years but these guys are ridiculously
powerful i mean are they on the same
level as catholic no probably not i'd
say catholic could probably defeat maybe
not the vashanti in their entirety like
all at the same time but like
individually probably but nonetheless
right hogoth is basically the guy who
has essentially been consuming quote
unquote the price to be paid for magic
right it's just one of those things
where it's kind of the role he plays in
relation to stephen strange in this
particular circumstance but regardless
he ends up approaching him because as a
member of the vashanti ultimately hogoth
could basically cure and essentially fix
emily and that's exactly what he does
right he basically cures emily of what
it is of this magic that's essentially
poisoning her entire body and then in
doing so another favor is owed to hogoth
now here's the thing to understand here
this is a big risk that stephen strange
is taking because so much of his power
stems from the shanty if at any point in
time they do what they did before which
is strip him of the title of sorcerer
supreme and take their power away from
him he is painfully weak right i mean to
the point where he's basically useless
there isn't really a whole lot he can do
because if he tries to use the spells of
the vashanti nothing's gonna happen he's
just gonna be some idiot standing there
saying words that nobody understands so
it's one of those things where like
these guys are exceedingly important now
of course the other part of this kind of
hitting back on the point we made before
in terms of the second reason why it was
that emily was so torn up about the
death of doyle dormammu is that she says
that when when zelma told her there was
a price to be paid for magic and they
were taking care of that price that she
didn't realize that it would ultimately
or could result in like one of them
dying that she believed that because of
the fact that you know everything was
taken care of they wouldn't really have
to deal with consequences for their
actions right just the nature of being
young kind of acting and then thinking
later on and so what this means is that
for her she saw herself as being
reckless leading her friends into uh
into a battle they couldn't possibly
hope to win not fully understanding what
was happening and that's when she starts
to get so angry you know when zelma says
you know we do the best that we can do
you know it's all we can do that's when
she gets mad and she's like it's not all
that you can do right like you took me
to wherever why can't you take doyle to
dormammu and have dormammu bring him
back and that's when stephen strange
says because it's not that simple when
they were trying to bring emily back
jericho drum brother voodoo had taken
off to the dark dimension to try to get
dormammu to basically resurrect his son
it's not something that you just do
right you don't just walk into the the
realm into the dark dimension of
dormammu and ask a favor right like he
would probably just destroy you right
just for inconveniencing him right
that's probably what you'll probably be
his motivation there and so ultimately
stephen strange is like you know doyle
is a descendant of dormammu as you can
see by your by the current state of your
headmaster asking someone to travel to
the dark dimension to ask for help from
one of the most powerful beings in all
of the multiverse is not that simple
that what happened here everything
that's going on right you can be angry
all you want to and you can point
fingers but your life hung in the
balance because of the many mistakes
that you made emily bright like
literally throwing on her shoulders and
saying like you're the one who made this
call you're the one that led your
friends there and you're the one that
basically led to doyle dormammu
ultimately dying had you not done what
you did doyle dormammu would not be dead
and he doesn't feed her over the head
with it in order to like tear her down
he says it because it's true because
it's absolutely true right and so the
results of this is that she actually
again acting reckless tries to take off
to the dark dimension and simply can't
do it and ultimately she's rescued by
steven strange who brings her back and
says look i understand what it is that
you're trying to do but at the end of
the day you simply cannot just roll into
the dark dimension what you're dealing
with here or is a level of malevolence
and evil and power that you cannot even
begin to comprehend this is not some
villain of the week this is not some
small time guy who wants to rob a bank
this is dormammu he will annihilate you
and there will be nothing that i can do
if you go there and he makes his choice
because i cannot overpower him in his
own dimension that's the level of power
that he has there and so ultimately
emily just kind of has to acquiesce and
she has to accept the fact that her
actions had led to the death of doyle
and so as a result of this she kind of
ends up going back right when they try
to pull her away she's like look just
give me one more second right at least
let me say goodbye she kisses doyle on
the forehead and when that happens doyle
comes back to life we don't exactly know
how we simply just know that she
basically resurrected him by giving him
a kiss on the forehead right the power
of love
[Laughter]
love conquers all especially when you
kiss the forehead of of a
dark godly magical being but nonetheless
you know there are a couple little funny
moments that go on here i kind of
following this this it's really funny
the way this is handled by scotty young
he's like cool doyle's alive all right
so back to business as usual guys so now
we're in the class of agatha harkness
and i get the hardness basically you
know brings in what's referred to as the
illusions of icon for those of you guys
who remember the events of infinity war
when doctor strange created like a whole
bunch of illusions of himself those
duplicates that's the illusions of icon
right being able to duplicate yourself
several times over now the kids kind of
go through and a lot of them are trying
and a lot of them are struggling as you
would expect emily's able to pull it off
right which is kind of a kind of the
thing that we basically see here at this
point but again it's a cool little
moment because one of the things that
happens here and this is pretty
important one of the things that happens
is in the middle of her lesson with
agatha harkness she's visited by steven
strange and stephen strange is like i
need you to come with me right like we
need to go take a look at something
right we need to have a bit of a
conversation and where emily is just
convinced she's convinced herself she's
going to be expelled from the school for
getting doyle killed stephen's like no
that's not going to happen right instead
uh doyle basically you know kind of came
to me and wanted me to give you a little
piece of himself right his this kind of
energy crown basically that kind of sits
around his head but it's like as a thank
you for saving his life right it comes
in the form of a ring uh and that you
can essentially hold on to it right it's
this little piece of himself given to
you as thanks for you saving his life
and emily's just kind of like i mean
yeah right like i look good you know
it's one of those things right i mean
she absolutely adores the gift that
she's given but when thor shows up of
course she starts to freak out because
literally thor walks in and he's like
wizard i have need of your assistance
as thor only ever does when he shows up
to visit somebody that's one of the
things that i loved about strange
academy is like you end up seeing
characters just kind of showing up here
you know that you wouldn't normally
expect to see just small little moments
you know like while doctor strange is
hanging out with emily and teaching her
magic uh thor comes by because thor
needs his help with something you know
because you know that happens but as
she's leaving of course she ends up
hearing that kind of disembodied voice
that she had had heard before but didn't
quite know what it was and so the
results of this is she basically kind of
makes her way to the sealed door and as
it's talking to her there's this really
really interesting conversation that
goes on where it kind of uses the
somewhat distrust she has of stephen
strange as those guys as a as a way to
kind of eke in and say that's why you
should trust me right kind of almost
like reverse psychology you know where
the two of them start talking and he's
like so so you know with this whole
thing that you're in right i mean you
question steven strange he kind of he
pitches this in such a way where he's
like you know you should let me out
she's like well i don't know anything
about you i don't know if you're telling
me the truth and he's like that's true
he's like but you do trust steven
strange right in her response like yeah
i mean i trust them as much as i can you
know but given everything that's gone on
i'm a little uncertain about it and he's
like and of course you trust jericho
drum and you trust all those people and
she's like yeah he's like so if you
don't trust me as a person that's on the
other side of the store why do you so
blindly trust magic and its worshippers
you don't know anything about stephen
strange outside of what they told you
you don't know anything about anybody
else they lied to you about the idea of
the debt being paid for using magic so
if you can trust them you could trust me
i'm not a bad guy right like i'm here to
help you out ultimately it doesn't
really seem like she does right and she
just kind of ends up leaving or sort of
walking away but it is a pretty
interesting little scenario and so there
is a kind of interesting situation that
goes on here where we actually focus on
calvin right calvin being the the bigger
kid uh you know really really excited
and kind of out there doing his thing
but ultimately a year before he ended up
coming to the strange academy he was in
his foster home and when the questions
asked by his mom you know did you take
my credit card uh he's like no and she's
like don't lie to me right he's like i
swear i wasn't the one who did it and
then she said then where did you get
that fancy leather jacket from his
response is of course i found it and
then she's like you know found it where
it says take it off you don't need a
coat at the dinner table in the end he's
like it was in my closet right i figured
one of the previous foster kids must
have left it here or something like that
but because of the fact that he just
refuses to take the the coat off his
foster father ends up getting angry and
then starts beating him and so what ends
up happening is seemingly by controlling
his coat he in turn seizes control of
his foster father and kills him and then
kills his foster mother and then that's
it right so obviously calvin despite
being very upbeat and very you know
happy go lucky and really a bubbly guy
has a pretty sketchy past right has a
pretty checkered past here but there is
a little bit of light hardness that goes
on in the sense that it's actually
family day at the strange academy right
the parents are here and the parents are
hanging out and it's kind of a cool
thing now ultimately i mean it is kind
of fun right you end up seeing like them
going on races and you know competing
and different things like that uh loki
of course is there and loki cheats as
you would expect loki too emily's mom is
incensed right she's just so mad
here's this mortal woman who probably
coupon clips and she's just like
screaming at loki right like this guy
could just kill her by poking his finger
through her head and she doesn't care
right hell has no fury like a woman's
scorn and loki's learning the hard way
but the funny thing that kind of goes on
here too is jericho's like okay he was
like now that we we we have this whole
thing figured out you know this you know
loki cheats that happens but he's not
gonna do it again right loki you're not
gonna cheat anymore uh he's like we move
on to our next thing all right next our
obstacle course and i call it the parent
trap and he's like the rules are simple
your whole team must complete the course
to win and then like as he's continuing
emily's mom is like we've all been to
family events before right we've been to
family picnics we know how races work
and i felt kind of bad for jericho drum
because like he had this big speech that
he was making that was gonna get
everybody amped up and then like emily's
mom was just like we know how this works
and he's like okay fine you know just
race you know and it's it's kind of sad
but it kind of makes you feel bad for
him but ultimately we switch over to uh
calvin and uh doyle because of course
doyle's father dormammu is not really
welcome to a uh to the strange academy
family picnic because as we know he
would probably try to use that
opportunity to conquer the world you
know like thank you for the picnic
stephen strange i enjoyed the hot dogs
and the hamburgers and now for conquest
you know like it would be something like
that so it's not necessarily something
that you want to have and for calvin of
course given what we know about his
parents in his darker history they're
obviously not here as well because
they're nobody's problem anymore they're
not anywhere they're six feet under but
the thing about this is that as he and
doyle are just kind of learning about
magic and the different things that
exist inside the strange academy and
really doing some exploring and probably
messing with things you're not
necessarily supposed to mess with
they're ultimately met by the arrival of
the mindless ones now here they're
technically called the mindful ones
because unlike the mindless ones that
you normally see in the dark dimension
which is actually what kaiselius and all
those guys were turned into at the uh at
the end of doctor strange i don't know
if you guys know that at the end of the
doctor strange movie but the mindless
ones were basically taken over by
dormammu and those guys and his and his
sister umar when they conquered the dark
dimension and so because they were
essentially enslaved they have a hatred
for dormammu so even though the mindless
ones who are here are not really the
same as the ones from their dimension
they all come from the same place and so
when they see doyle they see doyle's
father and it leads them to a place of
anger right like they initially attack
him and that's when you end up seeing
the power of of calvin manifest really
for the first time since he's been at
the school where he becomes kind of a
darker persona of himself right like his
eyes get dark you know his his like his
leather jacket seems to come to life he
becomes this just dark and and twisted
person right he's smoking cigarettes
listening to the cure he's just a really
dark guy and so the results of this is
that his powers basically unleash they
manifest and when that happens it fights
off the mindless ones and then in turn
of course it frees doyle and following
that a kind of bargain or agreement is
struck between the two of them that they
simply just won't tell anybody about
this particular thing that goes on now
following that you do get a bit of a
field trip this isn't really overly
important there are a couple things that
do go on here um the first one is that
for the the two asgardian brothers that
their father you end up learning their
father is basically a guard right at
asgard so he's not he's not really like
a super special guy right like he makes
sure nobody breaks into like that room
over there right basically what he does
but then you end up finding out that
their mother is actually a mora the
enchantress which is kind of crazy uh
because of course with her basically
being one of the villains of asgard
she's kind of locked away in prison that
kind of a thing and there is a bit of a
takeaway in the sense that she talks
about the prophecy one that has really
kind of reached the ears of everybody
who's familiar with magic this prophecy
being that like some kind of an event is
coming that is going to essentially test
everybody at the strange academy and
could potentially even lead to the
destruction of the world the only real
indication we have of what that event is
is when the kids were in new orleans and
they ended up meeting with that cirrus
who basically touched doyle and then saw
that potentially in the future both
doyle and his father dormammu would lay
waste to the world they would kill
everybody right every single superhero
is this everyone right just incinerate
the entire planet but again we don't
necessarily know if that's the case the
other part of this is that doyle out of
curiosity about what it is that eric's
doing ends up following him and that's
when he learns that eric's mother is
more of the enchantress and so because
everybody in the magical community knows
that amor the enchantress is a villain
he's ultimately kind of like okay look i
mean you got a sketchy dad i got a
sketchy mom we'll keep this secret
between the two of us the other thing
that kind of comes on here which is a
really cool little moment i really like
it right this is one of the reasons why
i love teenage superhero stories right
young love takes me back
that you have emily who is looking for
doyle ultimately finds him and then is
just kind of like you know like should
we you know when windows like should we
go back i mean they're going to come
looking for us she's like i mean we
could or you know we could hang out you
and me right how young people find
situations in which to express interest
but they're too nervous to actually say
anything you know like what are the
girls shooting their shot they send you
a text with a smiley right like that's
not shooting your shot shooting your
shot is saying can i buy you dinner
can i hold your hand right that's that's
shooting your shot
but nonetheless you know it's one of
those those funny little things because
she's young she's nervous he's young
he's nervous so he's like i mean it's
just like like just you and me hanging
out together and she's like yeah he's
like cool we get to hold hands
[Laughter]
and spend time alone together and like
you're my girlfriend now you know it's
hilarious right just young kids
and so it's a really really cool thing
because this really kind of solidifies
really what we've kind of known this
entire time that emily has a thing for
doyle and doyle has a thing for emily
it's really cute right and it's really
really adorable to see them just kind of
relating in that way and there's a kind
of nervousness right scotty young
handles this perfectly in the way that
he writes it there's a kind of
nervousness here you know where where
he's like you know it's just you know
this this is all just so beautiful you
know and and she's you know and he's
like i wasn't just talking about this i
was also talking about you and she's
like oh thank you you know and she's
like well you know i also want to thank
you too and he's like you know thank me
for what you know i didn't do anything
when we were in the swamp except get
killed he's like well you sacrificed
your life just you know that kind of a
thing you know kind of kind of back and
forth but ultimately like they end up
making the move one of the things that's
important here this is for all you young
guys out there this is one of the most
important things when it comes to just
being able to win over a girl make her
laugh if you can make a girl laugh that
means she's having a good time with you
but i mean the world's hard enough as it
is being able to make somebody laugh
makes all the difference in the world
and when you're talking about a
potential romantic attraction between
two people being able to be funny being
able to just kind of let yourself be
silly occasionally it can go a long way
and ultimately it wins emily over
because the two of them end up locking
lips right is smooching but it's really
cute because the rest of the kids end up
arriving on the scene they're like oh
it's so enjoyable you know so adorable
seeing the two of you all kissed we knew
it was only a matter of time they're
like but uh we need to get out of here
because we basically started a bar fight
uh here at asgard right like it wasn't
really supposed to be that way like they
were supposed to go there at asgard on a
field trip they were supposed to meet
with thor they ultimately ended up
meeting with volstag who came walking
out eating like a turkey leg which
admittedly i probably would have done
the same thing i probably would have
been like all right y'all uh so i'm
supposed to give you guys a tour of
everything and i will but let me finish
let me finish these ribs first
he ultimately ended up taking them to
the place where you can get like the
best food in asgard nobody had any
complaints right like show me the person
who's just like you know what i i don't
want to go to a good restaurant i want
to go see something else instead and i
would just be like what is your problem
right like we all love food so it's one
of those those cool little moments there
but following that this is where we
really get into kind of like the at
least one of the the big threats right
kind of the the being behind the wall
and for those of you guys who are
familiar with the early run on dr
strange right the combination of jason
aaron's run dennis hopeless run a tour
degree donnie kate's run also you guys
recall you guys will probably remember
what it is that we're sort of covering
here but you end up having toth right
toth being from weird world and is
ultimately just attacked by whatever
this being happens to be and then like
that's it right hoth has just shattered
now ultimately because he's from real
world because he's part he's part
crystalline you can bring him back the
problem is you need his heart to do it
and whoever it was that essentially
destroyed him took his heart so they
knew what they were doing and so even
when his family arrives on the scene and
they're just kind of like i mean there's
got to be a way for us to bring him back
when the revelation is that his heart's
gone they're kind of like okay well then
now we have to find somebody who can
figure out who took the heart of of toth
so we can find a way to bring this guy
back and that's when you end up finding
out jericho drum basically brought in
howard the duck right like scotty
young's pulling out all the stops man if
it has to do with some weird or magical
stuff then you'll basically then howard
the duck will somehow be involved in it
and because of this point of mobile
comics he's a private investigator which
really works perfect for howard the duck
there's never been a time where he's
been written better than being a
detective right being a private
investigator he literally goes through
and questions every single person right
just questions what they were doing what
was going on and the reality here is
everybody has an alibi whether their
alibi is covered from their social media
posts or their alibi is covered from
other people saying like they saw them
doing a thing no one really saw anybody
doing anything right everything was
copacetic but then as howard the duck is
investigating he ends up finding this
little butt right that was kind of left
behind and that's when he's like okay so
like this little button could have come
from anywhere but most likely it came
from a leather jacket specifically from
the jacket of calvin because he's got
buttons all over his jacket right so it
makes the most sense that it could come
from him combine this with the fact that
as calvin is basically there kind of
hanging out and doing his thing then he
reaches into his into his pocket and
pulls out the crystalline heart of toth
he doesn't understand what's going on
he's like i have no idea how this got
here like this is crazy right but as
everybody starts surrounding him they
start asking him questions they start
kind of bombarding him with this idea
that like he's the one that did it then
suddenly he snaps and he ends up
reverting back to his darker self and
that's when howard the duck and like
jericho drum and all these guys come
running in they're like everybody stay
away from this guy right and even even
calvin goes as far as to say like
everybody back up or i'm gonna end up
hurting you and what he ends up doing is
basically transforming into mr misery
now for those of you guys who are
unfamiliar with that mr misery is
ridiculously powerful right he's
incredibly powerful but here's the thing
behind mr misery so the way this was
established at least as it was
introduced is that with stephen strange
from the time he became the sorcerer
supreme even running up into the
formation of mr misery that there was a
physical toll that came with using magic
that one does not simply just use magic
willy-nilly and that's it right there is
an actual physical toll that comes with
it it harms your body and so because of
the physical pain that he was enduring
what stephen strange would do is
literally conjure up this pain in a
physical form that ultimately coalesced
in misery and that's why misery has its
name because it is quite literally
misery itself given a physical form not
only that once mr misery was originally
unlocked or kind of released steven
strange had to face off against it
steven strange had to consume it that
ultimately mr misery ended up freeing
itself from steven strange but the
problem was it couldn't just bond itself
to stephen strange again otherwise it
would face probably destruction more so
than defeat and so what it ended up
doing was literally just kind of
entering out into the world and then
ultimately stumbling across calvin
because calvin was a person who had
basically known nothing but misery over
the course of his life that mr misery
took the form of his jacket and then
basically started granting uh calvin the
ability to manipulate magic and so when
calvin had told his parents i didn't
steal your credit card i just found this
jacket in my closet he was telling the
truth the reality was because he had
experienced so much suffering and so
much abuse he was the perfect host for
mr misery that the two of them kind of
working in unison mr misery could kind
of operate behind the scenes subtly
influence calvin and then get calvin to
a place where he could re-enter the uh
the the presence of steven strange and
mr misery could in turn find a way to
destroy steven strange so he wouldn't
have to worry about being defeated again
or anything along those lines and so
what you get here because mr misery is
so powerful that everybody's attempts to
defeat him none of them really work
because they're trying to use
conventional magic i mean every single
student here jericho drum the whole nine
yards they're all trying to defeat them
but what ends up happening is that in
the midst of all this you end up having
desi who basically steps up now remember
desi is from the realm of limbo right
basically the realm of hell and one of
the things that she says or that she
realizes is that with mr misery because
he is suffering it's like adding the
color purple to the color purple all
you're gonna end up doing is making more
purple so for for mr misery himself you
can't really defeat him through
conventional means using magical energy
that he is a concept given physical form
much in the same way that cosmic
entities are the only way to truly
defeat him or to seemingly truly truly
defeat him is to quite literally give
him the thing that makes him more
powerful but give it to him in abundance
to basically feed him to the point of
bursting if what he wants is despair if
what he wants is horror if what he wants
is suffering then desi says i will bring
you that right i will bring you pain i
will bring you despair i will bring you
suffering in the hopes that you will get
what you want and it'll destroy you in
the process and so being a a individual
from the realm of hell she literally as
a person who is in charge of basically
holding on to despair and sadness and
hopelessness it's kind of the role she
plays in terms of just her existence
that she literally channels all of this
into mr misery following that everybody
else starts jumping in and everybody
else starts doing the exact same thing
right just dumping in all their sad
they're they're they're terrible
experiences right the the things that
have made them so unhappy the things
that have made them sad it all gets
channeled directly into mr misery and as
that happens it literally starts to
overpower him to the point that he
simply can't contain what is in essence
all this stuff that he's getting and so
he really just kind of shuts down you
know for a brief moment which gives desi
just long enough to basically consume it
and so seemingly mr misery is now
defeated and effectively locked away and
so what you end up getting of course is
a kind of happy ending here right is
that where calvin doesn't really seem to
have magical powers anymore because all
of his magical power was granted to him
by mr misery but also has this feeling
that he never meant to hurt anybody he
never wanted to do anything that brought
anybody any pain or suffering that it
really was mr misery working through him
he suddenly just didn't know it he would
quite literally block out for the most
part whenever mr misery took over that
instead of shunning him and instead of
the students just being like that guy is
a problem instead they actually rally
around him right they rally around and
they're like it's okay right i mean
these things happen sometimes like we're
literally dealing with a with a school
that handles like all kinds of crazy
magical stuff this was not your fault
you were being used by a magical force
out there whether or not calvin gets to
stay is something that only time will
tell right we'll end up finding out as
that progresses but there is a happy
ending here in the sense that his
classmates rally around him and they're
like it's okay calvin we still love you
so toth is okay everything's fine with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end i love strange
academy it's just so fun so now we gotta
wait for basically the the next story
arc to essentially finish and then go
from there but i will catch you all
later
peace
you